es clérigo musulmán chiíta y político es
un jugador clave en irak
múqtada al sádr pertenece a una
prominente familia de intelectuales y
religiosos y es considerado descendiente
del profeta mahoma en 1999 sadam husein
ordenó asesinar a su padre un ayatolá
pero cuatro años después con saddam
derrocado múqtada al-sadr tomó las
riendas de su legado familiar los
suburbios de bagdad conocidos como
ciudades adam fueron rebautizados como
ciudad sadar en honor a su familia entre
2003 y 2008 la milicia de al sadar luchó
contra las fuerzas estadounidenses
autoproclamado nacionalista chiíta al
sadar se opone toda la influencia
estadounidense e incluso iraní en irak
un hecho que diferencia su movimiento de
las milicias chiitas subordinadas a
teherán
irak pertenece sólo a los iraquíes todas
las armas deben estar en manos del
estado de duda
en 2016 sadar lideró el primer
levantamiento antigubernamental en la
naciente democracia de irak tras aliarse
con los comunistas su movimiento obtuvo
buenos resultados en las elecciones
parlamentarias pero los años siguientes
revelaron una serie de cambios de
sentido se alió con sus antiguos
oponentes para formar un nuevo gobierno
que luego desautorizó participando en
otro levantamiento contra el sistema en
2019 antes de volver a cambiar de bando
al año siguiente algunos manifestantes
han acusado a su milicia de matar a
varios de sus miembros pero aún logra
concentrar a miles de personas en las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales que
convocan